we know that there is no greater
equalizer than
a strong education and i think that
having a strong foundation for our
children
is a must-have as a mom as a teacher and
as a councilwoman who wants to see
her children be successful in our
schools
a high quality pre-k is of most
important so
super excited we're bringing it at 28th
and wardell right across the street from
east las vegas library and adjacent to
new public housing town homes
and this is really to benefit our kiddos
that come from
hard working class families that come
from at-risk
schools are going to be fed into at-risk
schools and
i just think having that foundation and
their curiosity
really being awakened and their love for
learning because they're getting a
strong start
is only going to help them be successful
and be the leaders that we need tomorrow
the other though exciting thing about
wardell that is very unique
is that it will be kind of a full
service location where affordable
housing has gone
in and there's a health center coming
online as part of this
there's the new east las vegas library
which is a fab
fabulous library and opportunity for
families so
it's that community space that we are
very excited that is unique
to wardell but not all of our facilities
have
well we are really excited about the new
strong start academy at wardell
it is our first new built pre-k academy
it will be our fourth academy that we
are bringing to the community
and this one really ties in to the area
i believe it's going to be
transformative with the new library
right across the street
it's also going to have a health center
built into it
um adjacent to the housing that the
housing authority is building so really
going to provide a
strong start for the children in the
area there's lots of schools in the area
and it's going to give those children
who need it the most an opportunity to
be in pre-k